also I saw you in Esquire yes five fits
with thank you Adam Pally and Esquire so
if you guys aren't familiar Esquire does
this whole thing where they basically
get people have them dress up in their
own personal wardrobe and have a
conversation with them and that was
really an easy one uh like sometimes
you're like promoting something and
they're like come in and do this like
photo shoot whatever and you get there
and you're like supposed to be in like
you know some crazy get up or whatever
like we're gonna do this like Buster
Keaton thing and you're like you're in a
barrel and you're like I can't fit in a
barrel like I yeah you know like so it
was nice to be like just just wear what
you'd wear you know we talk about
fashion a lot on the Stern Show but it's
more so making fun of how somebody
dresses how would you rate Gary
delabate's style I don't want to do this
today you both of us start with me start
with me first sign your intent dude you
always know exactly what you're doing
you and I feel like you you I mean you
know that and and so that's why you
wanted to go first Gary taking off his
jacket right now because I already made
a comment about it and he's embarrassed
no no if we're in a rating style like
you're the only people who can see me
this is what I will say about my style I
do not have great style but I'm
embarrassing No One You're Gonna mean
like wow
I think your sons would beg to you know
what when I look at you and I see
pictures of you your style seems very
effortless it seems very natural thank
you um but do you remember when you
became deliberate about the things you
started to buy yes I was a young kid I
became deliberate and I was influenced
by what I saw
early on like there you know first was
Michael Jackson and then that led into
like New Kids on the Block which led
into like crisscross which then was huge
and then my digable planets they're uh
it's still kind of like that for me I
think I feel like I'm easily influenced
but I think I try to like you know just
kind of be like what would my version of
that be so that I don't feel like I'm
wearing a costume because I do remember
being a young kid and like trying trying
a Vibe on yeah and then sitting in
school being like I don't feel
comfortable like in this like yeah
Marilyn Manson Cape you know like this
doesn't it's not for me so imagine if
you work on the show and instead of in
school where two or three of the kids
might be looking at you the entire class
just put you in the middle and threw
[__] at you because you're getting paid
you're getting paid I know but still I
remember once I don't know what I was
thinking I tried uh super long
basketball jersey thing you know what
I'm talking about wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you were
wearing like a little Wayne are you
serious yeah
is there a picture of this is there a
picture of this it wasn't like that it
wasn't like down in my knees but I had a
Knicks jersey I wore a next jersey with
the white t-shirt underneath it and I
came in and Howard and Robin were like
uh-uh no can you just imagine Gary like
in the background of like The Block is
Hot video with a [__] bandana on in
it oh my God I paid money for that I
could see Gary in the Petey Pablo video
on like a four wheeler
North Carolina
take your shirt off
oh